[MUSIC]
Hi Shih.
>> Hi.
[LAUGH]
>> How does it feel-
>> Hanging out for like 20 minutes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Still awkward, right?
>> How does it feel to be back in front
of everyone you're not on Zoom anymore?
>> Yeah, it feels nice.
We had a game last night in Portland and
it was first time really that
we felt a full house with fans.
Last year at the end of the season we
had some fans back in the building but
not a full house.
And last night you could just feel
the energy was like everybody was so
excited just to have some
semblance of normalcy.
So this feels good to it's
good to be back with people.
>> Yeah hopefully we recreate that
energy or tonight going to stock.
Before he got dive into the interview,
wanted to share,
if you do want to show us the bottom
half of your face, you have two options.
Stay hydrated so lots of water or
option two we've been told as if this
was a performance in actually remove
your mask if you want to shoot some
three pointers for us, let us know.
>> So
I can actually remove this if I perform.
>> Absolutely.
If you shoot your career percentage
tonight when you can automatically remove
that yeah.
Anyway, let's dive in, in all seriousness,
>> So the mask stays or goes which one?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I don't see a ball.
I don't see who.
>> Do we have a basketball
in the crowd here somewhere?
>> I could juggle maybe.
>> A judge maybe any other
performance would also do?
>> I think I really know
how to do anything else.
I should.
>> You don't want you to put us to shame,
to be honest.
I think that's the real reason
we don't have a basketball here.
But thank you for being here at the GSB.
We're super excited.
We think we have a lot to learn from you.
Not just Steve Kerr, the player,
the general manager,
the head coach, but also the podcast host,
the social commentator.
So you want to dive in.
Let's perhaps start with leadership.
How would you describe your style
of leadership in your own words?
>> I think I lead my team a little
bit like I raised my children.
My wife and I did that together and
we always sort of gave them a lot of rope.
But they kind of knew,
they were responsible for that freedom.
And so I believe in the same
kind of leadership with a team,
you can tell by the way we play,
we're pretty fast paced, we're risky.
We shoot a lot of crazy shots,
especially Steph and Clay.
But I believe that the freedom that they
have makes them play more instinctively.
And then ultimately,
when you're coaching a basketball team and
the players, it's their team.
And so you have to give them the team, but
give them the blueprint for
how it's all going to work.
And once the culture is sad, and
the idea is sad about what we're trying
to accomplish of let them go and
then you just rein them in when you
feel like you need to rein them in.
So I would say that's kind of my style.
>> That's your style.
I heard freedom, I heard rest.
I also heard children.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I want to touch on that.
Where does that come from?
And I'm curious if this is from your own
time as a child and your upbringing.
Where does that start you just described
to us where did you find that?
>> Probably my own parents.
I was kind of a strange kid,
to be honest with you.
I was super competitive
at a very young age,
to the point where it was actually
kind of embarrassing for the family.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I say that only half jokingly but-
>> Give us an example.
What was the embarrassing part?
>> So like when you have
a family Easter egg hunt.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I don't find the golden egg and
throw a complete tantrum at the age of
five because I didn't find the golden egg.
That's kind of embarrassing for
the parents.
>> [LAUGH] We call that
competitive at the GSB.
>> Yeah, but that was kind of for
whatever reason,
that was the way I was wired and
it carried over to sports.
And so, I think my parents
were really interesting.
They gave me a lot of rope and
they somehow they knew when
they go to my baseball games.
By the way, back then,
parents didn't go to every single game.
They just like if it was a Thursday
there's no way mom and dad were going.
It's like they might go on Saturday was
a little different back then I turn.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So sometimes I throw a complete fit.
If I got out or in baseball or
missed a bunch of shots and whatever,
I would just throw a complete tantrum,
my parents didn't really say anything
until later, like a dinner time.
They'd so
they somehow they instinctively knew just
wait until I cooled off a little bit.
And I think it was pretty powerful
because by that time you call off,
it's a lot easier to see what
you've actually done, right?
So I had to learn how to kind
of tame that competitiveness and
channel in the right direction.
And I think my parents
really helped me do that.
And so
I think that probably is in some way,
maybe subconsciously kind of
the way I guide my own team.
>> Right, I want to touch more on
your upbringing and your parents.
You were born in Beirut.
Your father,
Malcolm was also born in Beirut.
There's a lot of movement
between Lebanon and Egypt,
other Mediterranean countries and
then Los Angeles.
Your father was a professor.
Not many players or GMs or head coaches
have that experience at that age or
that point of their career.
How did that exposure to the international
culture impact you will have shaped
not just the leadership style but
your worldview moving forward?
>> Yeah, it was probably that
the best education I received as
a child growing up was living overseas.
I was born in Beirut as you mentioned.
I've lived in Cairo Egypt for about
three years when my dad was a visiting
professor at the American University there
and we spent time in France and Tunisia.
And so I had a really good experience in
terms of just seeing other cultures and
living in other cultures seeing
especially in Cairo abject poverty.
And seeing how wonderful the people were
and yet how little so many of them had.
When you're 10, 12 years old,
that's really powerful.
Especially coming from Los Angeles
where we were, you know,
my dad was a professor at UCLA and
we spent a lot of time on campus.
And it's kind of this idyllic,
seeing just like here in Stanford and
some of the contrast, and
it's great perspective for
a young person to feel
that at a young age.
>> Right.
>> And then I think you naturally sort
of build some empathy, but perspective.
And I try to introduce perspective
with our team as often as I can
at something Gregg Popovich was
amazing with in San Antonio.
And I think it's really crucial just for
all of our players to understand
how lucky we are to compete and
play basketball for
a living and be able to,
Come into the gym every day and
be together, it's so much fun.
And most of the world is trying to get by,
so we're really incredibly blessed.
>> Yeah.
>> Are there specific
stories from that childhood.
The time in Cairo seeing the abject
poverty, that come to mind that
I've started with you that you
perhaps have shared with players.
Or colleagues or
your staff that you've held on to.
>> There's an area in Cairo
called the City Of The Dead.
And it's, when I was there, this was
in the early, late 70s, early 80s.
There were like a million
people who lived basically in
a cemetery underneath the seas,
the cemetery area.
Obviously a pretty brutal nickname for
the place.
But I remember driving by it and asking,
why is it called the City Of The Dead?
Well, this is a burial ground and
a lot of people are,
living here because this is
the only space they have.
How do you reconcile that with, life and
Pacific Palisades going
to UCLA basketball games.
And thinking,
the world was a pretty easy place to be.
And so,
they got all really stuck with me forever.
>> Yeah, thanks for sharing that.
I feel like the way you
shared that in that emotion,
it's still very live with you and
carry that on.
You mentioned Gregg Popovich as well.
One of, in my opinion at least personally,
I'm sure you'll agree.
The best leaders out there and
not just coach but leader in the NBA.
You've worked with him.
You've also worked with
Phil Jackson at the Bulls.
When your leadership style,
is anything you found from either
of those two that you have drawn.
And you would like to embody
yourself with your team.
>> Yeah, I mean,
almost everything that I do is
a reflection of either Phil or
Pope or Lute Olson.
But the thing that I really
learned as I went is that,
if you're not authentic to yourself, your
players are going to feel that right away.
So, while the influence is
there from all of those guys.
And, definitely a lot of
the basketball drill work and
the philosophy comes from the people,
I learned.
Playing under,
it still has to be my own values that
I share with the team every day.
Because that's going to be authentic and
they'll feel that authenticity.
I was really dealt an amazing
hand when I got here.
Because, most first time coaches take over
bad team and we already had a good team.
But, the opportunity to
coach Steph Curry and
I could go on with a number of players.
>> Right.
>> In this conversation but
Steph in particular,
because I think we share too really
crucial values that define our whole team.
And that is joy and competitiveness.
Steff is just vicious competitor, but
you wouldn't know it because of the way
he looks and the joy that he plays with.
We see the world in a similar way, we've,
we understand the power of competing for
something.
But the power of joy within that and
so finding that balance
every day is kind of the key
to what makes our team tick.
But to be able to coach someone
who shares your values like that,
is just an incredible asset for
a coach, for a leader.
And to have somebody like Steph who's so
strong in terms of his own leadership.
It's been just incredibly blessed.
>> Right, you touched on Steph, and
I want to maybe dive deeper
into a part of leadership.
And that's people management.
A lot of us here at the GSB
will graduate entry jobs or
we perhaps have to manage
our direct reports.
And those beneath us in the org
chart as well as upwards,
water managers or bosses and so on.
You've had a similar experience.
You have to manage, GM,
President, operations, owners,
as well as your own staff,
players and so on.
What framework do you use?
What's your mental model when thinking
about, leveraging authority, both upwards,
downwards and sideways,
>> I think just being aware of everybody's
challenges and trying to remind
yourself on a daily basis.
That every single person in
the organization has challenges,
vulnerabilities, strengths, weaknesses.
We're all trying for the same thing, but
it's very natural for there to be blame.
The front office might sign a player and
doesn't turn out,
maybe they draft a player and they don't
think we're developing the player well.
Or maybe our coaches are thinking well,
we should have drafted
somebody like all that stuff.
There's the potential for
that every single day,
just like in any business, right?
There's so many people,
when you get so many people involved.
There's potential conflict.
So, I just try to think of, obviously,
depending on what's
going on with the team.
Just try to think each day of,
who do I need to check in with and
maybe it's just a phone call or an email.
But maintaining those lines of
communication constantly like you said,
managing in every direction.
It's really crucial.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's a big part of the job, right?
>> You mentioned communication there and
I want to maybe touch on
that a little bit more.
This is specifically around creating
a culture that is both diverse and
inclusive.
So, we hear that a lot.
I want to focus more on the inclusive part
which is not just having a diverse set
of individuals on the team.
But making them feel like they belong.
They have a voice,
there is open communication,
regardless of where they
are in the org chart.
I think back it was in June 2015,
NBA Finals Game 4,
you started Andre Iguodala for
the first time.
And I believe there was
a Wall Street Journal article about this.
That a 28 year old video assistant
who was fairly junior on your staff,
came up with an analysis
do from Q to do that.
Can you tell us more about kind
of what that story wasn't there,
was a 3AM Jack's message also
involved in there somewhere.
What enabled a junior staff member to
have an impact which then automate on to
the Finals MVP?
>> Yeah, well, it's one of the things
I really learned from Pope,
playing in San Antonio.
He used to say all the time,
anybody can have a good idea.
It doesn't matter where it comes from.
Let's explore everything and if one of
you has a thought, bring it up, and
he would say the same
thing to all the coaches.
And so it was very inclusive there and
I thought that was really powerful.
And I wanted to create
the same sort of culture here.
And so that was the way we operated,
we sort of embraced all ideas.
I encouraged everybody, all the coaches
to talk during during meetings.
And if it had something to say
to try to get it out of them.
And same thing in the huddles,
take a timeout and yeah,
we might see something as a coaching staff
and the players might feel differently.
And, so, I'll sometimes,
I'll say in the timeout, hey,
I'm thinking we should do this,
what are you guys think.
And usually it's Draymond who says,
no, we should do something different.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But Draymond's really smart, and
he's the one who is out there.
And so a lot of times, like, all right,
if you guys feel strongly about that,
let's do that.
>> Yeah.
>> But to do that, you have to be
comfortable in your own skin, and
you have to embrace, I think,
a really crucial aspect of leadership.
Which is that you actually will
come across stronger to the people
you're leading if you show that you
don't have all the answers, right?
I think sometimes leaders feel like,
my gosh, I've gotta have all the answers,
otherwise, they're not
going to respect me.
I think it's sort of the opposite, as long
as they know you're putting in the work
and that you know what
you're talking about.
Because what we're doing is more art
than science, it's a basketball game.
So there's no perfect answer for anything.
So if you can be collaborative and
sometimes allow the players to make
a decision or the video coordinator-
>> [LAUGH]
>> There shouldn't be any hesitation to do
that as long as you don't blame
that person if it doesn't work.
You gotta own the decision afterwards,
and whatever it is, and
give credit if credit is due.
But if you just do that and it comes
naturally and you feel comfortable with
that, it's a really powerful force
because then the players take ownership.
But doing that while maintaining your,
Your sense of you're
the person in charge ultimately is kind of
the balance that we're all looking for.
>> Yeah, yeah, I see a lot of
similarities with what you said earlier,
about leadership is giving that freedom,
that rope.
Allowing them to feel like they're part of
the process and they have ownership and
then actually being the decision
maker with all the inputs yourself.
Perhaps, more specifically
on people management,
there was a situation I
believe back in November 2018.
The Warriors were playing the Clippers
down in LA, nationally televised game.
There was a confrontation on television
between Kevin Durant and Draymond Green,
two of your superstars.
When you had to deal with that situation,
that confrontation, what learnings from
your past experiences, you mentioned
Popovich a couple of times and others.
What did you lean on in that moment
to diffuse that situation and
move on from that situation,
which was potentially a pretty difficult
confrontation that had just occurred?
>> Yeah, that one was a tough one, I had
never experienced anything like that,
where two players got into
it in a game like that.
So I think that's more
instinct than anything.
I think as a leader, as a coach,
you have to have kind of non-negotiables.
The players need to know
what line can be crossed or
what line can't be crossed, and
just felt like that was too much.
And Bob Myers and I got together and
handled it the way we thought was best.
There was no easy answer, and we just
tried to do the best we could with it,
but it was very, very difficult.
And obviously, when you're doing it
with the public staring at you and
knowing everything that's at stake,
it's not an easy position to be in,
but it's going to happen.
When you're in a leadership position,
there are very difficult
decisions to make.
And you just kind of have to do what you
think is best, I think, and what's right.
>> Yeah, yeah, and like you said,
in your career over many decades,
that was the first time you
had even come across that.
So there's always a curveball around the
corner, there's always a first time for
any situation.
I'm sure you've learned a lot from that.
What have you taken away and kind of
what's stuck with you going forward?
Now it's almost three years on,
how has that incident and dealing with
that new scenario changed your opinion or
style in people management?
>> Well, how many people here are going to
tweet about it if I answer it with-
>> Yeah, keep your hands down, yeah.
>> [LAUGH] This is part of modern life,
it's really difficult.
It's harder and
harder to live a public life and
really open up and
share things that happen.
Because all of a sudden,
things come right back around.
And so that's one that was very,
very difficult to deal with.
And obviously, Draymond brought
it up a couple months back, and
then it started all over again.
And so not my favorite-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Topic to
discuss, so-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Great.
>> Can we talk about
the championships that-
>> Great, yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Let's talk about that.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [LAUGH]
>> And hopefully another one coming up
next year in terms of championships-
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
>> So yeah.
>> Good, yeah.
>> I want to dive into perhaps
decision making, Steve.
And perhaps I want to go back to
a couple of different scenarios, and
if you could share with us
your thought process or
how you came to those conclusions,
decisions, I think that would be helpful.
The first one was fairly early on
in your time with the Warriors.
I believe there was a potential trade for
Kevin Love,
who was just coming off a stellar year,
with Klay Thompson,
who at the time was still
fairly young in his NBA career.
I believe you were very much for
Klay staying on the team and
not having that trade.
And of course, as they say, the rest
is history, Klay's been an all star and
won three titles.
What gave you conviction in that moment,
backing and supporting a fairly unknown or
unproven player versus more of
a genuine kind of proven expert?
>> I think that I've been in the NBA now,
in some capacity, for 33 years.
And one of the things I've learned
is the only thing you can be
sure of is what's already
been proven on the court.
Any time you decide to draft someone or
trade for someone, if there's no history,
if there's no proof that it's going to
work, you're really taking a chance.
And so when I became the Warriors coach,
the undisputed truth was that the Warriors
had the fourth best defense in the league
with Klay Thompson guarding a lot of
the point guards that are out there.
And it had become a really pick-and-roll
dominant game by that point.
Now it's even more so, and
you've got Klay and Steph.
And from a basketball standpoint, you'd
like to be able to protect Steph because
he's going to have to handle the ball so
much, maybe put Klay on the point guard.
I mean, and it had already worked, and so
our thinking was we know the Warriors
have a great defense already.
So if we can improve the offense
a little bit, and we thought we could.
Watching the tape, we thought a lot of
young guys who, with some more seasoning,
could generate better shots,
and it was all right there.
Whereas you make a big deal, even if it's
for a great player, you just don't know.
And so I think, in most cases, you're
wise to stick with what you do know,
if what you do know is really positive,
which it was.
>> Right, right, and where did
the training of that eye and that talent,
that conviction come from?
Was it just seeing Klay and
Steph in the prior seasons and
the shootarounds in the trainings?
Or was there something else in your
experiences that made you believe that,
no, this can come true,
let's just give it some more time and
actually see this come true?
>> Yeah these guys were
pretty young at the time, and
were already really proficient.
Steph was already an all star,
Clay hadn't been one yet.
But you could see the potential, and
they were in the playoffs for two years.
I mean, they were great,
this is a great team.
I inherited a team that was
the 150 games that have been
the playoffs the previous couple years.
The previous staff under
Mark Jackson had done a great job.
Establishing a defense, Warriors hadn't
had a defense in literally like 30 years.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So they were the team that just scored
125 points, and
usually the other team scored 127, and
that was kind of, they were fun to watch,
but they weren't going anywhere.
And so it was established, under Mark,
that they were going to become
a great defensive team, and
the front office did a really good
job putting the pieces together.
So when we got here,
when my staff got here, it was like,
this is real,
we could win the whole thing.
And that's why ultimately we
decided to stay the course,
and it's always Bob's decision, and
Bob was right with me in terms
of seeing where we can go.
Because we already had a really
good start with the momentum they
had built the previous couple of years,
right?
>> You mentioned inheriting a good team,
and
it was your first season as
a head coach at the NBA level.
And you win their first title in 40 years,
I believe,
the next year you win 73
regular season games.
You break your own team, 72,
then record of the Bulls.
A lot of people here also
potentially will experience fairly
rapid rises to success,
almost overnight success.
What, if anything, changes, Steve,
in your approach to management,
and just kind of how you approach
your day-to-day at the job,
when you've now gone from a challenger
to now at the top of that throne,
and to being that champion?
>> Really, nothing changed.
It was, I think,
the routine of making sure we're staying
locked in on the goals that we had,
trying to improve on
the certain keys that we thought
would take us to the next step.
And so, I think the whole idea with
anything is to build a culture,
kind of an atmosphere that
the players are going to
feel whether you're winning or
you're losing.
And the whole point is to help
the players get better, and
help them have the best
possible careers they can have.
And so that's true whether
you're winning championships or
you have the worst record in the league,
the goal still is the same thing, right?
So, as long as you're generating
that feeling in the gym each day,
then you have to be
comfortable with the criticism
that's going to come your
way when you're losing.
Because that's all part of it, and
it's just part of the territory.
>> Right, and how do you think about
managing, perhaps, the pressure and
kind of the magnifying glass that
comes with being at that job?
And you said the criticism, the blame.
You mentioned nothing changes day-to-day,
but
as we draw from students into
the post-graduation, real world,
how do we think about using
overnight success more tangibly and
thinking about our next steps in a way
that, perhaps, you were previously
not exposed to, and you were not at
the top, and not in that limelight?
>> Well, first of all,
I think life is more difficult now
than it's ever been for all of us.
Whether you're in
a position of leadership or
if you're a young person trying to
figure out what you're going to do.
Just the nature of life now
with the constant criticism and
judgment that we all
have at our fingertips.
That's so difficult to avoid.
I know when I played, literally,
if you wanted to avoid any of the chatter,
you just didn't pick up the morning paper.
And I had an experience in Chicago,
I was trying out for the Bulls, and
I had a non-guaranteed contract, and
I was just trying to make the team,
and I was playing great.
And I decided to pick up
the paper one day, thinking,
maybe they're going to say
something nice about me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Pick it up, and
you can probably guess
where the story is going.
The writer says, well, the Bulls are
going to make cuts in the next couple of
days, and Steve Kerr's probably
going to get cut, and so and so
is probably going to get cut.
And I was crushed, I was like, what is
he talking about, I'm playing so well.
The next day at practice, I was terrible.
And so I think about that
story sometimes because,
now it's like times a thousand for
everybody, right?
Whether you're trying out for an NBA team
or just trying to get through high school.
Hearing all the judgment and
the criticism, and it's brutal.
So, how do you navigate that?
How do you avoid that?
And so, finding balance, what I've found
with our players is the guys who have
the most balance in their life are the
ones who handle all this stuff the best.
Work-life balance is just crucial.
The days of coaches sleeping
in their office all night,
maybe there are still
coaches out there doing it,
probably in the NFL,
I think that's their thing.
But it's just insane, I think you have to
have a life, you have to have balance.
And Steph has a great example,
he loves life.
He loves his family,
he loves playing golf,
he loves being with his kids,
and being at home for dinner.
And every day is a gift to him,
and so he takes plenty of heat.
He takes plenty of criticism.
But he's able to manage it and navigate
it, and we've had a lot of players
who haven't been able to because
their lives aren't as balanced.
And so I guess that's my advice,
is to really seek balance,
that work-life relationship balance.
And I find it through,
I do a lot of yoga, I like to read.
I find if I can get into a good book,
I'm just kind of in a better
frame of mind each day.
And I like to cook,
just cooking a meal at home.
I'm not a chef, but
if I can find a good recipe,
I just go buy the ingredients and cook.
And have a game on in the background,
and have a beer, that's a great day.
>> Yeah, that sounds fun.
>> Yeah, but
that helps me when people say,
why the hell doesn't Kerr run
more pick and roll for Curry?
I can just cook a meal and have a beer.
>> Yeah, that must be nice.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But, like you said,
not all your players have that balance,
you mentioned Steph, and he does that.
What is your role as a head coach to,
is it a nudge in the right direction?
Is it more explicit than that?
How do you want to kind of corral as
many of your roster towards that?
because you've clearly seen
the benefits of that balance.
>> Right.
>> How do you do that?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
I think that's one area
where perspective comes in,
reminding Players,
just how fortunate we are.
And you can do that in variety of
ways bringing in guest speakers.
We're very lucky because people
want to come speak to the warriors,
and so we're able to get a lot of
really interesting people to come in.
And we've had Michael Lewis came in,
the author came in to speak to our team.
We had Dr. Dre and
Jimmy Iovine came in and
did give a presentation on their company,
on Beats.
We've had Alicia Keys and she came in and
talked about her process of
writing a song and writing music.
We've had Tommy Smith,
the sprinter from the 1968 Olympics,
who held up his fist for racial equality.
Some incredible guests and so
trying to present something
to the players that is not just,
here's how we're guarding, pick and roll.
It's like this is-
>> This is life.
Right, and then beyond that, we try to
offer them as much assistance as we can in
terms of we have a mindfulness
coach to help them with meditation.
We'll do some of that as a team and
then they'll have private
sessions where we try to help
people to get comfortable learning
how to perform under all this
judgment we all live under.
>> Right, yeah, and
perhaps this is judgment.
Sometimes, I see a double standard for
the athletes and the people under
that spotlight versus the rest of us
who are in a more of an office 95 job.
For example, a lot of jet
companies during the Bay Area,
have unlimited paid time off.
They have unlimited vacation days and
so on.
When that say LeBron James does it,
it's called load management.
If he misses the Primetime game, people
are upset, their television rights and
sponsors and so on.
Is that fair?
Is that a double standard that we have
as a society between our athletes and
everyone else?
>> Yeah, but that's part of the deal.
We try to talk to our team every
year about what the NBA is about.
When you're playing in the NBA,
you're going to get booed.
You're going to get criticized.
You're going to get injured.
You're going to get cut,
you're going to get traded.
But if you can navigate it well, it's an
amazing job and you're going to make a lot
of money and you're going to
have some great experiences, and
you get to play basketball for
a living and this is the trade off.
So you got to understand that right away.
I once had, I won't name,
this teammate, but
when I was late in my career,
I was playing for the Blazers.
And one of our rookies on that
team would sit with me and
another veteran player
guy named Chris Dudley.
And the coach,
Maurice Cheeks was the coach,
I think he wanted this rookie to sit
with us so we could share our wisdom,
we were both getting ready to retire,
we'd been in the league a long time.
And this player, first week of the season,
he says he's exhausted.
It's been a month of training camp and
games and
we're maybe a month into the season.
He says, hey guys, I have a question, and
he says, how much time do we get off for
Christmas?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Chris and
I kind of looked at each other like,
boy, this is going to be a long year.
>> He's got a lot to learn.
>> We don't have any time off for
Christmas, you can see he was heartbroken,
he said, we don't get any time off at all?
And no, and it turned out the coach
actually made him go home for
a couple of days, he was so homesick.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
you kind of have to know
what you're getting into.
And one of the problems right now
with the league, it's not a problem,
it's more of an issue that players are
coming in at a younger and younger age.
We just drafted two guys
in the lottery who are 19,
they each spent one year after
high school and here they are.
25 years ago, It was you know guys
like Tim Duncan and Patrick Ewing.
We're playing four years in college and
doing what you do in college, growing up.
So to have to grow up in the NBA at 19 and
not really knowing anything
is very difficult,
so we got to try to do the best we can.
>> Right, I want to move on to perhaps
some of the work you did last year while
the world was in lockdown, on you had a,
if I trust all flying coach,
I believe with Pete Carroll.
And there was a specific episode,
I believe that was June, early June,
when you had Brad Popovich as it asked,
and
this was right after
the George Floyd murders.
And you described your
thoughts on that issue.
You described how a player of yours,
I believe Andre Iguodala,
had to tell you about the Tulsa riots,
despite you having been a student
of American history in both
high school and college.
And I think the words used to describe the
moment was an absence of leadership in our
nation as a disease.
This is very much issue with
specifically the white population.
About a year and a half on, Steve, what
are your thoughts on those topics today?
How have we changed?
How have we improved, if at all?
>> Yeah, it's so hard because we're being
held back by the incredible division that
exists, the political
division that exists.
What Andre asked me, he said,
did you ever hear of the Tulsa race riot?
I said no, this was year and a half ago.
Since that time, a lot has come out,
there's been documentaries.
But my point of the time was, I took
several years of American history and
never heard one word about that.
Our curriculum in high school and
college when it came to African American
history was mainly Jackie Robinson,
and Martin Luther King,
and these figures who we celebrated for
good reason.
But we didn't flip it around.
We never said, okay,
why was it that Jackie Robinson wasn't
allowed to play in the big leagues?
Why weren't black people allowed to
play in the big leagues before that?
We didn't ever really explore
that in school, right?
And so
now there's this movement a year ago and
I think everybody who's
involved in this movement,
the whole point is we need to
reconcile some of our sins, right?
Our original sin especially.
We need to exempt.
We can't just ignore it,
which is what we've done.
Because you see how it's
manifested itself in so many ways.
George Floyd's murder being an easy
example and a terrible example.
But I think the point is,
what's happened now is so
you immediately get this conversation
on critical race theory,
which is just nothing more
than a fancy way of saying,
hey let's teach real African American
history to our kids.
And it seems so simple, right?
It's like, yeah, that would be really
good, and maybe kids could grow up and
learn that racism is really bad, and
teach them at a very young age, right?
Because it's clearly something
that is sort of taught.
And yet all of a sudden that
become the argument is, well,
we don't want to teach our kids that
they're bad and they're bad people like.
Nobody's suggesting that.
But this is how every issue that we
have in this country now becomes.
It's like this and it's all for political
gain and it's really demoralizing.
And it's just another example of how we're
sort of flailing right
now as a country and
in trying to get our shit together.
>> While the politics of
it play a massive role and
would meet all of our lives a lot easier.
What can we as individuals perhaps, do on
an individual level in our communities
with the people around us, and then you
shared a little bit about this earlier,
but tell us more about how you've
had perhaps those uncomfortable
conversations with your team,
with your family and your community.
>> Well, I think I think number one,
we need to educate ourselves
the best we can, whether that's,
through our own reading or
just extending ourselves and and
in a way that we haven't done before.
Bryan Stevenson is another
incredible guest speaker.
We had the civil rights lawyer
>> And he talks about proximity,
and he said, proximity is so important.
And we asked what he mean by proximity?
So well, proximity to the people
that you're trying to help, right?
Puts on the ground,
if you really want to make an impact,
actually being approximate to
people you're trying to help being,
in the community in some form
of a grassroots organization.
Movement can, what can you do that
actually is going to not just make
an impact but make you feel it make
you feel what's actually happening.
And I think that's what the NBA
has really tried to do,
every team now is connected with
a local grassroots organization
that is trying to Improve the lives
of people in the inner city and
trying to do positive things
in terms of racial relations.
And so
I think that's the challenge is how do we
actually feel it and be proximate to it.
>> I love that, I had not heard that
analogy with proximity before but
I think being present and
as close to the source of the difference.
Just stepping that Steve,
the George Floyd murder and
racial injustice is just one issue of
many in justices that are happening
around the world and some are captured
by the media some are not.
How do you as a leader and
as a person with a platform,
decide when to speak up on an issue and
an injustice versus whether to not do so.
And we too will most likely be in
the situations in the business world where
there's a lot happening out there with
our employees, our staff, our community.
What's the framework we can use?
How can we think about what do we
need then when do we when do we not?
Now?
>> That's a great question.
I think what I've realized is to
narrow down my focus to the things
that I'm really passionate about and
informed about.
It's really difficult to to go down the
path of hey I want to be an activist and
start talking about something you
really don't know a whole lot about.
Those issues are better to set out and
so for me,
the issues that I'm most interested
in that have really been the biggest
Dynamics in my own life for
gun violence, and racial equality.
I lost my dad to gun
violence when I was 18.
He was 52.
And so gun violence is something that
it affects me deeply and my family.
So I've spent a lot of time with a lot
of the different gun violence groups,
gun, violence prevention groups,
whether it's Sandy Hook or
the Brady foundation Giffords,
March for our lives.
I've done fundraising but
I've also learned a lot and so
I feel much more comfortable.
Speaking out about
>> Those things.
And then the racial justice,
it's just, I'm living every
day with a group of people whose
lives are directly impacted and
whose families are directly impacted
by the injustice that exists and
so It's really easy for me to feel
passionate and connected to those things.
>> Yeah, it's not.
It's always going to be a personal choice.
But using the idea of being informed and
educated on those topics is
a droid starting way of desiring
where to lean into those issues?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think that's
sort of personal choice too.
I mean, I've been pretty passionate
about those issues for a long time, but
I just leaned into them.
Maybe five, six years ago.
I think I've told this story before,
but we think it might have
been the 2016 finals.
Maybe it was the conference finals, but
we had our third moment of
silence in as many weeks.
This was the Pulse
nightclub massacre Orlando.
>> Yeah, in Orlando.
>> And we were having this huge game and
we haven't yet another moment of silence.
>> And it's like so what are we just
going to keep doing this we're just like
it's great, let's honor the victims and
their families but maybe we should
excuse my language maybe we should
effing do something about it, right?
>> And it's just, it's infuriating.
>> It's infuriating and
I finally just had enough and
I decided just sort of apropos of nothing.
I was doing a podcast,
local podcasts with Tim Kawakami and
about basketball and I just I brought
it up and took a lot of body heat for
it from you know gun rights activists and
learned a lot but
it was good, it felt good and
it would be in it sort of got,
I dove in and
I started to get my bearings and
started to realize where I
could actually make an impact.
Yeah.
>> Thanks for sharing that I did
not know about that 2016 finals and
the podcast so that was inspiring.
Before we open it up to Q&A wanted to ask
a question which we plan to ask all of our
speakers this year for the from the top.
Our theme Steve is beyond expectations.
You've certainly in the stories
you've shared right now gone beyond
the expectations set forth by society for
a NBA player in GM a head coach,
if you were to perhaps just
summarize what inspires you.
what motivates you to grow
beyond just those expectations?
What would you say?
>> I think what I love about coaching and
what inspires me is this feeling of,
generating joy and happiness as a group.
Its gives me chills just thinking
about a team that's connected and
playing well and laughing.
I'm really excited about this year
we added our first exhibition game
last night.
And you know this Tara, but sometimes you
just feel it and sometimes you don't.
Like last night, I'm watching our game and
I just had chills,
like this group is connected, and
we're going to have a really fun season.
And that's what keeps me coming to work
every day and wanting to really succeed,
is that feeling of momentum
when you just grasp something.
Then you can feel it and it starts to
grow, and you're just tryna feed it.
And so many people are interested
in it and enjoying it as well.
And so when our team plays well and
the community gets involved and
all of a sudden everybody's excited,
that's the best feeling there is for me.
>> It's great and as a Warrior's fan,
you're getting chills on the first
preseason games, that is exciting,
it bodes well for the rest of our
season and I'm excited for that.
Great let's open it up to questions,
I think we have the first one right
over there,
you could just introduce yourself please.
>> Hey Steven, first of all, thank you
very much for being with us tonight.
I'm Sandy Apodaca class of 2023,
I'm managing ODM from Argentina.
I wanted to draw back in time to 1997,
game six against the Utah Jazz of
Club Madonna and John Stockton [LAUGH].
You called a timeout,
25 seconds left on the clock.
What were you thinking?
>> [LAUGH] [APPLAUSE]
>> How did you manage to convince
just Michael Jordan?
When you went into the huddle,
you looked him in the eyes and shouted,
if you need it, if it comes up,
I will be ready.
>> You might have planted this question.
>> I planted this question.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
>> You just told the story that was
the moment that every kid
dreams of when you're shooting
in your driveway or
a you're at school or whatever.
And you count down the seconds and
NBA championship on the line and
so to actually live that was incredible.
When you're a kid when you miss,
you just pretend that you got fouled and
now you go to the free throw line and
you shoot two free throws.
But when it's happening,
you can't quite have that luxury.
But it was a moment that I think
it took me a long time to get to
the point where I could actually
succeed in a situation like that.
I was very self conscious when
I started playing in the NBA,
and I didn't really feel clutch.
I felt like I was thinking too much.
And so I learned a lot, especially
from Michael Jordan who took game
winning shots almost every week and
missed plenty of them.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
didn't seem to bother him that much.
And there was a great lesson in
there that you gotta go for it.
And you gotta be able to live
with the failure if you don't.
But the the best way to succeed is
without considering the failure,
just playing, just going, and
getting out of your own head.
And so that was a moment for
me that was probably years in the making.
And so obviously a great, great moment and
something I'll have forever.
>> Next question, we have one back there.
>> Steve, thanks so much for
speaking with us today.
My name is Tejas.
I'm a first year MBA student here.
And my question today is about
building championship culture.
This is tough for me to say as
a lifelong Cleveland Cavaliers fan but
if you could take us back to 2015.
What were your top priorities and
values that you sought to
instil in the organisation?
And who did you work with and lean on to
help build these values and priorities?
>> Yeah, thank you for the question.
And congratulations on
the 2016 championship.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So when I became a coach, I spent a lot
of time preparing to coach, but
I didn't become a coach until I was 49.
So I did some television work
after I was done playing and
I spent a lot of time preparing and
I talked to a lot of coaches.
And one of the guys who really made
an impact on me was Pete Carroll and
I went to see Pete in Seattle.
I love the way his teams played.
And I sat down with him and he just said,
after we had spent a couple of days
together, and I was watching practice.
And he sat down in his office and he said,
so how are you going to coach your team?
I said, you mean like what
offense Are we going to run?
He said now that stuff
doesn't even matter.
And I just spent like a year trying to
figure out what our offense was going to
look like.
He said really that
stuff you'll figure out.
He said it's what's it going to
feel like for the players and
the coaches to come into the gym every day
and what's your culture going to be like.
And I suppose I had never really
thought of it in those terms, but
I knew playing for Phil and Pop,
they had built these amazing cultures.
But Pete really sort of clarified and
he told me the story
of how he sort of figured out
how to incorporate a culture.
And he asked me to go home and
think of the four values
that were the most important
values in my life.
And that my job as a coach was once
I figured out what those values were,
was to make those values
come alive every day.
And that the players would feel that
authenticity since they're my values.
And so Pete was the guy who
sort of laid it out there and
it was really fascinating.
Joy and competition were two of them.
Mindfulness was another one.
Everything that we did was
built on competing and joy and
mindfulness and
compassion was the fourth one.
So everything we did and
the way we treated the team
was based on those values.
We incorporated a ton of joy
into our practice sessions.
We competed at everything,
we kept score of everything.
We treated our players with great
compassion, but making those
values come alive to me was the lesson of
this is what it means to build a culture.
>> We have time for
one last one over there, we'll wrap up.
>> Hi, this is Joe Ramirez,
MBA 23 from Mexico.
So my question is regarding
how you experience
different joys as a player and as a coach.
I practiced quite quite competitively and
one of my greatest fears has been
retirement because I feel that is a great
part of my identity
that I'm going to lose.
What has been your favorite
part of coaching and
how do you compare that feeling of winning
a championship as a player and as a coach?
>> Yeah a great question.
I think as player you're very locked in
on your own game, your own routine.
And as a coach,
you're thinking about everybody else and
you're trying to help everyone.
So actually I've found winning
The championship as a coach was even
more gratifying than as a player because
you've put in all this energy into
the whole group and you see how happy
everyone in the organization is.
And when you're a player,
it's an amazing feeling too
especially with your teammates.
But it's more insular.
It's more you're just locked in on
your own routine day after day.
And coaching is you feel responsible for
everyone.
>> Thanks for answering those, Steve.
We are almost done.
Before we let you go,
we want to do a quick lightning round.
>> Okay.
>> I'll mention a couple of words or
phrases and just,
you pick one of them, ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, Space Jam 1 or Space Jam 2?
>> [LAUGH]
>> 1.
>> 1, okay, so
does that mean Jordan over LeBron?
Or is that just an indictment
on their acting,
not their experience, just as actors.
I didn't see Space Jam 2 so.
>> Okay, there we go.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Messi or Ronaldo?
>> Messi.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> There's my Argentine guy right there.
>> What's your team?
>> Liverpool.
>> Liverpool FC.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> We have some Liverpool in here as well.
Roger Federer, Rafael Nadal,
Novak Djokovic?
>> Roger Federer.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Roger Federer okay, crowd pleaser.
>> Better dressed team,
1996 Bulls or 2017 Warriors.
>> Do coaches count?
>> [LAUGH]
>> You were a player one,
not a coach on the other.
>> 2017 Warriors because I was a player
96 Bulls and I brought the level down.
>> You brought them down.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's fair.
[LAUGH] Best city for food in the NBA?
>> Chicago.
>> And last one, losing game seven
of the NBA Finals to LeBron James
at home on Father's Day or getting
punched in the face by Michael Jordan?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Wow, that's quite a way to finish
tonight [LAUGH], really uplifting there.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Anyway, I don't know if you know this,
but I actually went at Michael and
I actually hit him in
the fist with my jaw.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We have an answer, that's an answer.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I think that was a winner.
But that was a lot of fun.
>> I get an ovation for
getting punched, that's [INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm not sure I understand, but
we'll go with it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Thanks for your time,
I think we learned a lot.
We really appreciate this to you.
I think you've left us with lessons on
mindfulness, on authenticity, on proximity
that I think we all can take with us
as we graduate and we walk onto GSB.
I want to wish you, your family, the team,
best of health and good luck for
the season and go Warriors.
>> All right, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you, thank you.
[INAUDIBLE] a glass of water.
[MUSIC]